Troubled Chinese developer Evergrande is exploring
a sale of its property-management firm as
part of a desperate-bid to sell-off assets
and raise much-needed cash.
The firm owes more than 300 billion dollars
in unpaid bills.
Beijing is worried about domestic unrest;
Foreign investors could be left empty-handed.
There's a complete standstill on Evergrande's
construction sites.. workers have long left
long, many unsure if and how much they get
paid for their work.
But there might be an end in sight for the
real estate developer's crisis that has shaken
investors' confidence for weeks.
Evergrande is selling a majority-stake in
its property management unit for more than
5 billion dollars, bringing in much needed
cash to carry on.
"The goal is to separate the Evergrande Group
into three different units and ask the local
government to provide enough money for the
Evergrande Group to complete the projects
on hand.
So that it can sell the completed flats to
the buyers.
And the buyers can pay the Evergrande Group,
who in turn will pay off the contractors.
So that, as far as the Chinese government's
concerned, this is the best way forward.
And of course, in doing so, I think some creditors
will be hurt, mostly overseas creditors."
These creditors have known for a while that
their investment is at risk.. and still, another
trading week begins with markets worrying
about possible contagion and the fall-out
for China's entire economy.